11 livres à lire en seulement 2 mois
c'est le défi que va relever cette
classe de première aile du lycée
jean-villard à Plaisir choisi pour
attribuer le concours des lycéens les
ouvrages sont les mêmes que ce
sélectionner pour le prix concours tous
les élèves de la classe lisent les
livres ou du moins un maximum de livres
ensuite nous faisons un débat h clos et
nous désignons un tiercé et un délégué
et ce délégué de classe ira pour les
élections régionales au mois de novembre
à Paris et là il y aura à nouveau un
tierc et un dernier tour pour une
élection nationale seul deux lycées de
la région Île-de-France ont été
sélectionné au total une cinquantaine y
participe à travers la France une façon
de mieux appréhender le bac français à
la fin de l'année et de s'ouvrir à la
lecture c'est une formidable expérience
de lecture donc nous avons des élèves
littéraires donc qui sont des lecteurs
mais bon tous ne sont pas forcément des
grands lecteurs donc là c'est vraiment
l'occasion pour les élèves de de
découvrir littérature contemporaine
puisque ce ne sont que des titres très
récents et de stimuler un goût pour la
lecture de déclencher un appétit de
lecture ouais une bonne expérience et on
va avoir plus de culture mais bon c'est
difficile parce qu'il y en a beaucoup il
y en a 11 donc bon faut faire vite quoi
j'aime bien lire mais je suis pas
forcément une grande lectrice de
classique plutôt des trucs plus modernes
type fantastique
romance le prigon cours des lycéens a
été créé en 1988 par la Fnac qui fournit
une dizain d'exemplaires de chaque livre
aux classes concernées il sera remis
début novembre quelques jours après son
aîné